ian is a was a saul kagan claimed
conference post doctoral fellow in
advanced showa studies in new york an
honorary research fellow of the center
for jewish studies university of
manchester
his research focuses his research focus
lies in the field of jewish christian
relations in eastern europe during the
holocaust his numerous publications
include the monograph titled the
romanian orthodox church in the
holocaust in an article about the
uh seventh rosiori regiment and the
holocaust in romania and the soviet
union which
was published in that pima is going to
be published
published in dapin
studies uh defeating which is a studies
on the holocaust and that was uh a
journal
article
um ian will be presenting his work on
survivor testimony that explores the use
of jewish to christian conversion as a
survival strategy during the war
uh please join me in welcoming young
[Applause]
he also has a
call yeah
i'm very sorry that my voice is not up
to the task but do
no no that's fine that's fine
um
my presentation today will have four
parts in the first i will explain
and actually let me go i will explain
how i came to study this topic of juice
conversion to christianity
in the second
i offer a brief overview of the history
of jews conversion to christianity
before and during the holocaust and how
this avenue was used as a means of
survival
third my presentation provides some
statistical data on my findings so far
in the fortunate version of archive on
this topic and last but not least i will
look at few testimonies
including one that will feature us the
annotated edition and examine some of
the major themes that transpire in them
during my phd
which is
well
this is for the
video recording um
don't think we have
a mic
there's no idea yes but it's for the
video oh okay
okay
okay
during my phd which resulted in the book
the romanian orthodox church and the
holocaust published by indiana
university press in 2017 i discovered
that in relation to the topic of juice
conversion
the main church in romania had to
address two issues
worse there were requests from jews who
were already converted to orthodox
christianity to
be protected by the religion they have
been members of for many years
unfortunately the holy see not refused
to offer any help not even to those such
as nicola solomonescu
jewish man who converted more than 30
years before
second there were requests for baptism
during the holocaust coming from jews
who believe that in this way they may be
protected by the increasing anti-semitic
laws in the second instance the romanian
orthodox church show indifference too
although it had a clear majority of at
least 72 percent of the population the
church offered this avenue to only
a handful of people this being in stark
contrast with the attitude of the roman
catholic catholic and lutheran churches
when i finished my phd i embarked on a
new project looking at the big
discrepancy between the attitude of the
orthodox and the catholic churches in
romania towards jews
although
the topic of conversion was not the only
one i looked at it was one of the most
important as the catholic church in
romania made it a matter of open
rebellion against the state and by the
way this is the papal municio to
bucharest andrea casullo
in romania there are two strands of
catholicism greek catholicism
which comprises of
ethnic romanians from transylvania who
are the beginning of the 18th century
accepted to be subjected to the holy see
and the regular roman catholics
both catholic churches were in struggle
with the romanian state which favored
the romanian orthodox church hence in
1941 when the antonescu regime banned
conversion of jews the catholic church
protested vehemently against the measure
in the coming years many jews who
understood that conversion to
catholicism might offer some protection
asked to be baptized
the catholics seized the opportunity to
show their defiance and continue to
convert in open disobedience
sometimes resisting direct pressures
from the state to stop baptism
as the antonescu regime wanted to
maintain good relations with the vatican
which was seen by the romanian leader as
a key political player in the future
peace conferences most jews who
converted to catholicism during the
holocaust in romania escaped deportation
and death
lists found in various archives show
that at least 2008 jews converted after
the march 1941 ban
this should be added to the
4631 jews who were already converts
during my research i was surprised by
the lack of information on the post-war
fate of converted jews i remember that
when i started my postdoctoral project i
discovered bashem lists of jews who
converted to catholicism in bukovina
i took one of these lists which
comprised of 108 names and tried to find
any information in the yad vashem's full
of names and other
paper and video archives at russia
at the time i also introduced the names
in the usa
usc shaw foundation video archive
unfortunately i found nothing
i even arranged a meeting with the
director of the hall of names who
explained to me that since they
converted it must be that these people
either did not identify as jews or were
not accepted or seen as jews anymore
in 1950s the case of daniel ruff
ruffay's son
showed that the converts jewishness was
strongly contested in israel
historian and sociologist ariel yakov
i'm sorry
mentions in one of his articles several
memoirs of political survivors that
discuss openly the topic of conversion
and it is striking that all of them were
written and published in the united
states
uh in the u.s the topic of conversion
appears more often in testimonials of
local survivors including in the fortune
of archive there are several aspects
that might explain this first it is
already generally accepted that ameri
the american identity is based on
multiple ethnic and religious layers
hence one does not feel the need to
define himself herself
in limited ethnic and religious terms
second the jewish community in the
united states is much more eclectic
and the definition of jewishness is more
nuanced than you in europe or israel
this might explain why a jewish convert
to christianity could talk openly about
convert conversion and still identify as
jewish in the u.s
but would have reservations to do so in
other countries
third since the definition of jewishness
is broader and more inclusive some u.s
u.s institutions that gather holocaust
survivors testimonies did not have any
problem of including testimonies of the
jews who converted to christianity
this was definitely the case with the
fortune of video archive the project to
gather testimonies of holocaust survivor
started in 1979 and i argued that from
the beginning it is visible the broader
scope and reach of the project
take for example one of the first
interviews done by lauren vlog laurel
vlog one of the initiators of the
archive in 1980 april 1980
with hans frey who was at the time a
respected professor of theology at the
yale divinity school
fry was born in breslau
in 1922 from jewish parents were both
involved in the medical profession
his father was a professor at the
faculty of medicine university of
breslau
and his mother was a doctor
the parents were much assimilated into
the german society they converted to
christianity in their early adulthood
in 1935 hans was sent to a quaker school
in england as a way of protecting him
from increasing persecution
in 1938 the entire family immigrated to
the united states
the problem of conversion and the
definition of one's belongings belonging
is in-depth debated in the dialogue
between vlog and fry
and although i have not found yet a
written document to confirm this it
might be that this early interview set
up later practice of interviewing
converts and discussing the way in which
the experience impacted their sense of
belonging
the fortune of video archive contains in
comparison to all other holocaust
testimonies archives i looked at a much
greater number of testimonies from jews
who converted to christianity before and
during the second world war
i relied in my findings
on orbeez the the search engine of the
year library each testimony has a brief
usually between 10 20 lines
or rows
in a word document this description of
its content
this tool is by not me no means perfect
and there might be other testimonies
describing experience of conversion that
since the word itself or alternate
versions
are not mentioned in the description are
impossible to find
using orbeez i deployed four types of
search first i searched using the word
conversion and 63 results came up
of the 63
48
turned out to be describing some of them
in great detail experiences of
conversion to christianity
in terms of gender 28 testimonies were
given by women and 20 by men
the vast majority were children at the
moment of conversion being born in the
late 1920s and during the 1930s only few
being born before 1920.
most conversions took place from 1939 to
1944.
only three took place after the war and
few others before
the most striking aspect was the
distribution according to the country of
origin which was in most cases but not
all also the country where the
experience of coercion took place
the preponderance of testimonies from
slovakia is surprising and difficult to
explain
as it appears even in the testimonies
themselves conversion in itself was not
providing safe shelter in slovakia
so this could not explain the large
number of testimonies and maybe of
conversions in this country
the possibility that there were
there was is a slovak community around
new haven hence more people were
interviewed as a result of geographical
proximity is not entirely explanatory as
testimonies of the fortune of archive
were gathered
in many other locations
another striking aspect was the fact
that there is no testimony from romania
including territories that were part of
greater romania in the interwar period
and are now in ukraine or moldova the
country
with the third largest jewish community
before the war
moreover i explained about as explained
above the number of conversions in
romania during the holocaust was
relatively relatively high
the absence of any testimonies from this
country could be a strong argument of
the way in which effectiveness of
conversion affected post-war jewish
identity and i hope we will be able to
discuss this more in the q and a session
after the analysis of the first 63
testimonies resulted from searching the
word conversion i looked up for three
more variants converted baptism and
baptized for the sake of um
time i will skip some details about
those findings that i will offer an
overall summary
the four searches produced 153 results
97 out of 153 were testimonies
describing in a form or another
experiences of conversion of the
interviewees
while the rest were either duplicates
or irrelevant as the word referred to
something else
all aware about conversions of somebody
else usually parents
and the mention was very brief
62 testimonies were from women holocaust
survivors and 36 from men the vast
majority were children at the time of
baptism conversion catholicism is
predominant but this was mostly because
most testimonies were from countries
where catholicism was the main religion
in terms of countries of origin it
surprises the large number of
testimonies from slovakia 26 this is
more than a quarter
and the lack of any testimony from
romania
in almost all cases looked at conversion
was a means of survival
it was not the only strategy of survival
and most often in itself was not helpful
or enough
but it was always combined with other
means of survival such as hiding or
providing forged papers
in some cases some means of survival
were refused without the step of
conversion
several historians have noted that until
today the topic of conversion has been
to a large extent avoided in holocaust
historiography but conversion was not a
marginal aspect of the holocaust
on the one hand as in the case of the
romanian orthodox church explained
earlier churches had to respond to jews
who were already converts
and i think it is stunning that the
topic is not carefully discussed when
one considers that in hungary alone in
1941 there were up to a hundred thousand
converts that is approximately one-sixth
of the jewish population of hungary this
including the territories added added
next after 1940.
although there were converts deported to
auschwitz and there are few such
testimonies in the fortune of archive
most of them were protected as in 1944
catholic and protestant churches
protested vehemently deportation of
converts
the number of converts was was high in
other countries too in russia for
example during the 19th century the
official number of conversion was 85
000.
slovakia although we lack clear figures
it is estimated
that in prague or bruno
at the beginning of the 20th century the
conversion rates to that
2.25 or 2.5 percent of the local jewish
population
hans fry puts the number of converts in
germany in 1933 at 15 000.
on the other hand churches had to deal
during the holocaust with another aspect
to convert and if so under what
circumstances jews who are seeking
protection
the case of romania where the catholic
church converted entire families in open
disobedience to state pressures is
singular
in other countries conversion was not
necessarily an official policy
coming from the leadership of the church
but a matter of local initiative and the
decision
for example there were cases of jews who
wanted to take shelter in a village but
the villagers said that they wouldn't
offer that protection unless the jews
convert to catholicism
this situation appears
several times in the fortunate
testimonies but i mentioned here only
the case of nw holocaust testimony
2356 who was from a town called radzilov
in poland she describes the scene when
her father asked the leader of the
village to help the family quote he
asked him if he could help us
there were some other people and the
first comment that that there was from
those people was as jews we cannot help
you
if you promise to convert then we will
try and help you
of course my father agreed end of quote
and since i mentioned on here i must
stress an aspect that
she mentioned
mentions and is not very often present
in testimonies the role of the parents
in this case the parents and children
were hiding together
in keeping alive jewish identity despite
conversion
and i have the clip actually from
would
talk to me
all the talk was wasn't listener because
my mother my mother being hurt
she would talk to me she was
being that i was the youngest and i
didn't have much education yet
she would tell me about the jewish
history and heritage
and she wanted to be sure that i know
who i am
and
and who my people are and she tried to
instill in me
the pride of being jewish
and not to think that because we are
exterminated
and
treated the way we are that we really
deserve that
and they and
she would tell me um
stories from the history about some
heroic
um especially heroic events that took
place
she would tell me that
in case i'm the only one
who would survive
to be sure to somehow get to a day
center where there are jews
and and to to go to palestine and and go
on with my life
and um
[Music]
and that that there's so much
beauty
in in the way of life of jews in their
daily living
the retelling of the story with these
heroic undertones was definitely
influenced by the interviewees situation
belief values as they were in the 1980s
when the interview was done still the
scene itself shows
the desire of parents to pass on to
their children their their ethnic and
religious identity in a context in which
they were in
to some extent foggy
yeah we should not forget that they were
converted already hiding but they were
still trying to maintain a jewish
identity alive
other parents did not have this chance
during the holocaust
the conditioning of help in exchange for
conversion appears often in attitudes of
religious institutions too
many catholic and protestant convents
and or orphanages
refused to take children inside unless
they converted
for example david k holocaust testimony
1856
who was born in bruno
explains that an anglican orphanage
based in czechoslovakia
conditioned the acceptance of the jewish
children on their baptism
while hiding in convents or in catholic
households
many jewish children felt persuaded to
convert sometimes there were
direct pressures
other times there was a win over
such examples
a win over the child being convinced by
the context in which he or she was
living
and there are many such examples in the
fortune of testimonies
archive
all these experiences impacted greatly
on these people's later sense of
belonging
on the one hand there was an internal
voice of consciousness telling them
especially if they grew in traditional
jewish families that by converting they
betrayed the jewish people the jewish
religion and community
take for example
susan m holocaust testimony
537
who almost converted as a child in
hungary to avoid persecution she
describes her experience in these terms
i quote and the issue was
this is the voice of the interviewer and
the issue was that you were learning the
catholic prayers yes
and you enjoyed taking
some lessons were you a good student
no
i was petrified the whole time and i
wanted to cover my ears not to even hear
it and i felt somehow that god was
watching us and if anything this was
going to be
the cause of our perishing
the next air raid or whatever just
because we were doing it
it was like like being a traitor and i
was always terribly ashamed
i i don't i
not ashamed of anything else associated
with the holocaust and i practically
talk about everything else but this is
something i've always been very
embarrassed about and
i was glad when my father kept kicked up
a fight and we got out of it end of
quote
susan m is only one example of many
others who had the same feeling of
betrayal
at this internal voice of consciousness
one should also add the outside of
problem in many jewish communities
converts were not welcomed back not seen
as jews anymore sometimes this implicit
pressure can be felt in the fortune of
testimonies when the survivors try to
answer and asked questions minimize the
importance of conversion experience
or
all of a sudden bring up israel as a way
of emphasizing their jewish belonging
and i don't know if you notice noticed
even in ann's case she's talking towards
the end about
go to palestine
although most fortune of testimony is
discussion discussing the impact of
conversion of jewish identity have this
stone
there are several notable exceptions
there were few conversions after the
holocaust in one case that was designed
as an explicit protest against jewish
religion and god seen as responsible for
what happened
so i i found such a case of a conversion
as a sign of protest
there were other cases such as
walter ziffer
testimony
1475
who converted after the holocaust and
after arrival in the u.s
out of conviction
zifer became a prominent evangelical
minister
but even in his case testimony one has
the sense of heroic return to judaism
judaism after almost 40 years
then there are testimonies of jews who
converted before and during the
holocaust in germany
in most cases
their retelling of the story of
conversion is not shadowed by feelings
of betrayal or embarrassment
and that is probably because this
community was much secularized
this is the case of hans frey
whom i mentioned earlier
after long deliberations i decided to
focus my annotated edition on his
testimony
christ's testimony is important for ea
university
as he was a professor
of theology here at divinity school for
many years
i also believe that this is one of the
first such testimonies from converted
jews recorded in the fortune of archive
and it set up later trends
the topic of conversion's impact on
jewish identity is discussed brilliantly
in this testimony
however this is also a very different
case from most of the cases i looked at
frye
first fry emigrated with his entire
family in 1938
he experienced the beginning of the
holocaust in germany but did not feel
like most other survivors the full blow
of persecution
fry did not have to take shelter in a
convent or to
be hidden conditionally by some
villagers or to convert as a way of
gaining the trust of a convent on a for
a foster family however his testimony is
extremely relevant because it shows a
different tone on conversion where this
decision is not dismissed as betrayal or
embarrassment nor minimized under the
glorious narrative of post-war return to
judaism
freud tried to make peace with his
hybrid identities
he explains this rather neutral attitude
in this way and i have again the excerpt
here
we have been so deeply assimilated
deeply assimilated
that on the one hand we were proud
of the fact
that we were jewish in a curious
undefinable way
we felt that we were jewish and that was
that jews were good people
but on the other hand we felt that it
was simply a kind of
cultural
religious
distinctness but not
anything that interfered with uh first
of all being german citizens
you see our whole world for just that
reason our whole world was turning far
more outside
in 1933
we were robbed of our primary support
namely our
national identity
which was much more our identity than
our jewish identity
this is a complex story because
you were converted you you claim you
felt jewish or you felt an
identification with your jewish heritage
ancestry
if you were practicing christians
in an assimilated german society it's um
how you the german poet who was himself
jewish and rather simply converted once
said that the that back the baptismal
certificate
is the admission ticket to european
culture
and a lot of jewish people
in the middle of the 19th century
especially in germany began
to feel some sympathy for that so that
even when they did not do it themselves
as my parents did they
downplayed any
part of their heritage except one of a
strictly limited religious cultural sort
there are several such exchanges where
laurel vlog is pushing fry to
confront his identity
towards the end of the interview she
confronts him one more time
and actually i will end my presentation
with his words which i think are a good
introduction to the q and a
this is laurel vlog
speaking that takes us back to you and
your family and the relationship between
you and your family which must have been
must be or must have been strained as a
result of your departure on your part
even though it was clear why it happened
my departure from towards christianity
you mean
well nah not really towards christianity
but away from the condition that the
family found itself in
actually no no that
the problem was not that there
the problem was it's not there the
problem i mean they they saw what i was
doing as a continuation of their own
pattern of assimilation on the one hand
and moving into an academic life on the
other hand
the problem really for me is that i am
far more than a good many other people
at once an outsider to jewishness and an
insider
i find that a very
difficult way of
unintelligible is not clear what he says
there i mean for example if this country
were to go officially anti-semitic which
i don't see coming but nonetheless it's
something like that i would clearly
identify my myself with the jewish
community but
why is vlog
asking well because i think one should
always identify with those who are
persecuted i think that's only right but
i think i would do so
as one whose persuasion is one of
considerable skepticism at the same time
there's another who wrote a deeply
moving book so i would read soul
freelander when memory comes have you
looked at it
and he has become a very loyal devoted
israeli and yet i think i find in that
book i found part of the same vein
a kind of inability to get two halves of
his personality together again
except in a very tenuous way
well that's true for me too
but you see
that my dominant personality became
secular and christian
therefore it would take a conscious move
rather than a
natural emotive response for me to
identify myself with judaism now i'm too
far gone and he smiles thank you
[Applause]
first of all i i wonder whether you can
you can say about the methodology you
will use
um in video testimonies because they
have made special sources for a history
for a historian for history writing so
how you can use these testimonies which
i discussed with
the position of the interviewers
but we
we haven't discussed yet the structure
of the interview
and the second question is connected to
the first
what about continuities and
discontinuities in these post worlds
because in the first story it is it goes
on for fashion and a profession
and
in the concentration camp it hardly have
ever happened
then once one can keep
his or her professional profession
so and in that way uh continuity or
discontinuity
with the case of faith it's totally
different than in the case of the lady
because he
understands himself in the framework of
assimilation
history of the central europeans choose
so the question is whether you can use
this concept of continuity and
discontinuity
within the case study you are only
conducting
let's go ahead and take a couple more
questions and then is that okay no
question
uh i guess picking up where we left off
are you looking into
how things
transpired after the war if if children
were left in convents and the parents
didn't
return to pick them up
uh whether the convent kept them whether
the convent
gave them to the jewish community
how did things play out
at the end of the war
in looking at the statistics that um the
reason that you've found so many from
czechoslovakia is because we had a huge
project in slovakia
i think it's not a legitimate
statistic
it has to do with where our projects
were set up
we never taken romania
we had
hundreds of tapes
done in check in in slovakia
and i think it's just that coincidence
i'm curious if you saw the testimony of
roof rising
no
okay is it in the fortunate we have it
we have a sister as well all right oh
um
so this is a case that shows that
the search itself is not comprehensive
because i couldn't find it
so applying the four types of search
the name of roof
didn't come up so
okay interesting
thanks um and the other thing is is the
major female dichotomy that you showed
and i i think that does tell us
something i think people were more
willing
to take women to take girls because they
weren't circumcised
a boy was immediately identifiable and a
girl was not
and i think some of that is a function
of that
um
and i'm
a little puzzled again i want to look at
the
records again
i know we have at least one that i can
call a romanian
little boy who was converted
and actually we edited it it's in our
edited testimonies and he talks about
how it bothered him even as a little boy
and he said he
felt
that god was going to punish him
because he was converted and dory has a
lengthy discussion with him about that
issue
it's it's called d
paul d yes
that's possible that i i can't remember
the geography exactly that he it may be
ukraine now and not remember yeah
but it was romanian when he was born and
been usually put down as a country
the name of the country
it was when they were home
i would be really interested to find out
that testimony yeah yeah
yeah sure
because it would be great to s to
finally see a testimony of somebody who
converted in romania that would be great
fantastic
questions
yeah sure sure
now coming to eva's first
um
i know that there are a lot of debates
about the methodology of interviews and
um
a lot of questions about
and especially with the fortune of
archive at the beginning
uh where there was no specific training
until they kind of created a framework
a structure
but at the same time i like the idea of
letting the survivor talk there are a
few testimonies i looked at when
some of them were in serbia
there was one in serbia where the
interviewer was actually leading the
was leading the interview
the ue
so he was asking so many questions
that it wasn't any more a testimony it
was
yeah something else
but no the
most of the cases i looked at um
and actually i i had a kind of
when i saw that like i kind of had a
question in my mind and i asked myself
was there a specific
and maybe you could help me here was
there a specific
realization that the converts should be
pushed
with these questions of identity
probably not because as far as i know
the question of identity would appear
anyway in all the testimonies the way in
which after the war the experience
itself
affected
these people's identity and maybe in the
case of conversion because conversion
was such a big
experience
maybe this is why the interviewer
asked a lot of questions and pushed
about
and how do you feel do you feel judy do
you feel how do you feel and
but i think these questions is great
that they are asked
uh because um
because the survivor is
um is giving his or he his or her
insight into what the way in which that
experience affected them
and
the results that the answers are
sometimes extraordinary you discover
either feelings of
embarrassment shame
um betrayal
or you discover like in the case of hans
fry and some others uh he is not the
only one i mean there are a lot of
others
that don't show the same
trouble
by the experience
but the fact that the interviewer asked
all those questions
made this
kind of clarification possible
continuity and discontinuity
yes and actually this is why i chose fry
because
actually i
i had a kind of dilemma
should i pick up testimony that is
representing the majority of the
converts i found the the testimonies of
converts i found
if if that was the case then i should
have picked up
a testimony where you you have this feel
feeling of embarrassment and
shame and betrayal and there are a lot
of these testimonies
but fry is different and i think
sometimes by looking at the different
case
you can
have a
a better sense of
what is going on
so in this case continuity and
discontinuity yes maybe in the
enhanced price cases discontinuity from
the regular
trend
now coming to your questions um
i i'm based
i'm basing my
kind of conclusion on what i find in the
testimonies so i i don't go i could go
to secondary literature about what
happened with these
children
after the war and i know
there are a lot of situations where
children were not returned to the
relatives
or
yeah what the situations but um
based on what i found and there are a
lot of testimonies from
children
there are
grown adults now
uh who were
sheltered in convents
there is one very interesting testimony
actually there are three testimonies
of
all of them are men boys they were boys
at the time
who found shelter in a
belgian convent
but they didn't know about each other
i think they didn't know about each
other even during the war
and then um after the war
there was a call i think in the u.s for
a reunion of all the people who found
shelter in that specific uh village and
convent
and this is how they met and actually
the testimony is interesting because
uh
they are interviewed separately and they
then
all of them are
brought together
and they are um
kind of disgusting joking and
remembering
the experience
in that specific context
um
what what surprised me most
is
the fact that this is not so
the topic of
children
converted in convents or catholic
households
um
is not a myth
it's something real and there are many
testimonies in the fortune of archive of
such type of conversions
um in some cases you see that they
they are still attached to that
experience
um but at the same time you as
an
observer
you feel that
the experience itself was not right i
mean they were taken advantage of
they were children not knowing too much
but they still were persuaded
in a way or another by families or by
convents to convert
i didn't find any situation where
a child
or a survivor talks about his experience
that he wasn't able to return to his
family or i didn't find such a situation
[Music]
thank you very much for your comments
it's it's great um
if if we could find out romanian that
would be the romanian testimonies that
would be great
women
women and the topic of women and
men i think your your insight is great
but at the same time i should point out
that
that was a trend
uh going back a hundred and some
years back
of women
being more
jewish women converting at a higher rate
than men
so that's uh that's a
all the statistics about conversion
um
would show that women converted more
but there were some other aspects that
surprised me i didn't talk about all the
statistical data here uh
usually we assume that um
jews converted in order to marry or for
career purposes but i found a lot of
testimonies mentioning conversions
conversion the other way around i mean
women converting in order to marry a
jewish man
there were a lot of such a lot of such
cases i mean in in one of the searches i
think were baptized or for
converted
i think there were like 40 results
and almost all of them were about this
type of so the
spouse converted to judaism
in order to marry that
[Music]
because you're dealing with some
children yeah uh are you
at a stage where you're able to
interview people or that's not within
your
your scope you know have you spoken to
self read lender for instance
no and i i must say that
the topic itself is a bit new to me uh
i'm a historian
and i'm not an oral historian i mostly
deal with documents
and i came to study this as a result as
i said as a result of the way in which
my research led me to this topic
[Music]
i didn't do interviews before
and i have to learn a lot
in terms of and eva is helping me and a
lot of other people at the vienna
visitor
in order to understand this
complex aspects of
interviews the way in which they are
done and
yeah
but no i i didn't do interview myself
interviews myself
do you see that on the horizon
well you still have the opportunity to
ask these um if i would continue to look
at this
topic yes maybe
but this depends because i'm still
carrying on with my other so my research
on churches attitudes
virtues jewish christian relations
is still there i mean i'm still
interested in
in
looking at the way in which
churches as organizations as
institutions behaved and
um but if i would uh if i would carry on
with this uh
type of research looking at the way in
which convert conversion affected then
definitely i would look into that but i
would also have to look into the
psychological aspect i'm not a
psychologist
but i i will have to
to
uh to gain more insight into the way in
which
because in some cases
and it's fascinating some people some
converted survivors
they are talking about as embarrassment
shame
these are very profound
very
kind of serious
terms
embarrassment shame and even trauma so i
found in one interview
one lady holocaust survivor
talking about the experience of
conversion towards the end of a specific
section she is mentioning the word
trauma
um and it is true i mean sometimes i
have the feeling that
these people all it is a trauma for them
because on the one hand
they
felt the betrayal that the father they
betrayed the community and the family
and the jewish
religion but on the other hand they
felt attached to that
experience there is one instance which
is very interesting um
the name of the survivor is nadia r
and she
says
the experience of conversion of baptism
is the first memory
so that's my first memory so that's the
first thing i remember
but immediately she says but that was
not important at all
so you see the you see the dilemmas and
the
struggles
to
at the same time to accept that that was
a powerful experience but at the same
time to say
you know that was not important because
i still define myself as a
children jewish were in convents or
monasteries who were not converted
but still
consider that a seminal experience yes
there are few such experiences yes there
are a few such experiences
i don't remember on the top of my head
now the names of those survivors but
there are
definitely
some cases there are a few cases where
interestingly enough
there were siblings
and one of them converted the other one
didn't
there were situations also when
both converted but after the war one of
them remained converted and committed
christian the other one returned to
judaism so there are a lot of uh
different
situations
you know that was a concerted effort
yeah
top down bottom up yeah saved the jewish
children and many many were placed in
convents in the monasteries and were not
converted yeah
but it was a seminal experience yeah
it was unbelievable it was in france as
well um belgium and france i think that
these are the biggest countries we have
this experience
um
yeah
the children forgot these christian
we're running out of time so let's thank
both of our speakers one more time
[Applause]
[Music]
you